with us as bob woodward associate editor
at The Washington Post he is no stranger
to blockbuster congressional hearings is
one of the reporters who broke the
Watergate story that eventually led to
President Nixon's resignation Bob
welcome thank you so we have testimony
yesterday in which James Comey calls the
president alive then the president
treats this morning James Comey as a
liar this began as a probe into whether
Russia was colluding with members of the
Trump transition team where are we on
the big story well that's the question
in the big story is about what Russia
did and that's what's got to be
investigated and what is missing here at
this point is a clear crime what Russia
did in the election last year it was a
classic espionage operation we are CIA
used to do this decades ago and so
you've got to find out who did that was
somebody in the United States in the
Trump campaign or Trump himself somehow
involved and that is a big task I think
we now have about five to ten percent I
have a 10% of the answers to the
questions we need and there's so many
and so many have to do with what's what
happened in Russia but that's exactly
what the FBI was trying to do and tasked
with and then we have the man who's been
in charge of this independent agency
saying before the world it's my judgment
I was fired because of the Russia
investigation by the President of the
United States I think that's true and I
think you look at the chronology and the
evidence at the same time you know what
was Trump thinking what was he doing in
Comey gives a window into this Trump was
obsessed with getting a public deck
relay declaration that he Trump was not
under investigation and call me told him
that three times and then never would
say it publicly you had have said it
publicly well I think he should have I
think you know his argument is well if
then Trump
came under investigation we'd have to
fix that we'd have to correct it but
there is a way and if you look at the
cliff for four months trump was
essentially begging tell him i'm not
under investigation was commis
credibility damage do you think bob when
he admitted that he leaked information
to a friend in hopes that it would lead
to a special prosecutor which it did i
think it actually was enhanced really
yeah because he was honest about it
he's like our old source deep throat
mark felt who was number two in the FBI
felt would meet in underground garage
lurking in the shadows and with Yomi has
come out with me yes and Comey has come
out and said look I wanted to get this
out I think we needed a special counsel
to investigate that that's are there
other compression with Watergate because
here we have in John Dean met somebody
who was on the inside yes James Comey is
not on the inside of the Trump
administration there is dramatic
difference Comey is not John Dean Comey
is a witness about what Trump allegedly
did Dean was so powerful this 45 years
ago as a witness because said look I was
the president's lawyer in the White
House and what I did was corrupt we led
the obstruction of justice the president
was in charge of this and I was
responding that way was there any
positive takeaway for a team Trump
yesterday in your opinion well the
magista argument that hey look why
didn't they tell the world that Trump
was not under investigation and if you
get into the chronology of this there
are two points where Comey waits two
weeks before kind of responding to what
clearly was president Trump's number-one
demand you get the impression though
that that the Trump team is a bit
relieved by this because they expected
perhaps he had things to say that he had
not said before that might be even more
damaging that's possible but it's very
damaging when Comey said look
one meeting the president said let the
Flynn investigation go
Trumpy a lot of people are saying no
Trump is new to this he's not a lawyer
if you check the record and I have
Trump's been involved in more lawsuits
than than just about anyone and he knows
you have to get legal advice and not do
that not get involved in this business
of telling the FBI director drop an
investigation that's that's off the
rails and way out of my we sat here
together all day yesterday and were
marked about how many times the former
FBI director mentioned tapes multiple
occasions was the reason he actually
released the memos to his friend that
then became in part of the papers he
said lordy I hope there's tapes do you
think their tapes you know I mean it's
always the best evidence if they're not
been tapes in the Nixon case he would
have been he would have stayed in office
I'm sure I mean we but say your Muller
the Special Investigator counsel in this
what is it you want you know what you
want you want a defector from Russian
intelligence to come to the United
States and I will tell you how we ran
this operation maybe all of everyone in
the intelligence community has been very
clear and very powerful and saying there
is evidence that everyone agrees
establishes that Russia did this now was
there money involved who was involved
who they say Putin directed it are there
people in this country that's why I say
we still have 90 or 95 percent that's
right work thank you let there be no
fuzz on that as Comey said yesterday Bob
Weber thank you so much